I think any time you're making fun of
powerful people that's a good thing I
think we need to we need to uh the
challenge is and the reverse is true
right the powerful people who want to
shut you down that's because they're
insecure yeah but but but I think you
know I think the world wants to see you
know a what becomes a problem is when
SNL only targets one sec that's when
it's kind of like so if you do both
sides I'm all in if you do one side
that's the part where some people are
like if Sasha Baron Cohen did that same
thing to both sides of the aisle I
guarantee everybody would go watch it
but when he does it only to one side
something like yeah you don't know I
don't want to see it because you're not
doing the hypocrisy on the other side
you know I feel like the left has a thin
skin
uh everybody's got a thin skin that's
the reality there are a lot of people
that think they don't ever thin skin as
soon as their size is going to be yeah
I'm kind of with you
these days the original board did make
fun of left-leaning people there was
that whole conversation with like the
feminists and everything it's true yeah
for sure they were definitely yeah well
can I give you one of who I thought was
one of the greatest trolls ever and it's
now these as vanilla as it gets as
Stephen Colbert when Stephen Colbert did
The Colbert Show and he portrayed a
conservative right-leaning Trump guy
even in the midst of
the Iraq war in Afghanistan it's like of
course we got to get in there they've
got uh weapons of mass destruction he's
like uh you know they they didn't he's
like you can't tell me any different
like the way he was able to troll and
this kind of goes back to my comment
about misdirection you know where
Stephen Colbert stands these days so
anytime he does a joke you know where
it's ending and I think that's sort of
the problem that left has these days is
that
we already know where you're going buddy
and that's the whole premise with comedy
and trolling and and sarcasm is that you
that's what I respect about Andrew
Schultz and what we talked about with
him Bill Burr Bill Burr as well is like
he'll go any directions you got to stand
up you know you know like for example
you know this whole thing you're talking
about the left or the right who can
handle it who can't take it one of the
greatest roasts of all time is Trump's
roast I don't know if you saw when they
roasted Trump and then you know what
Snoop said about Trump he says this
won't be the first time you uh uh got
rid of a black man in his house or you
kicked the I don't know if you remember
that line what he said first one and
then guess what he's sitting there he's
being trolled by everybody and guess
who's sitting right in front of trump
his daughter and his daughter's laughing
at the jokes they're saying about his
father about her Father which was kind
of great to see him in that shows a lot
of times they say he's got thin skin I
mean some of it can be credible but if
you got thin skin I don't see a lot of
left sitting there being roasted by you
know people in media space the the
Republicans didn't Trump literally ax
the uh White House correspondent no no
I'm talking about I'm talking about no
no but I'm just saying in terms of like
who can handle it levers is right I
totally get that but the first the first
the first person you think about when
you say he can't handle it the first
person everybody goes to is who Trump
because he's got you know he's got thin
skin everybody's like oh he's got thin
skin if you got thin skin the last thing
a thin skin person would do is to follow
him I'll give you a judgment on this
here you can kind of let's have some
banter on this one sure so for example
um yesterday Kyle came on the podcast
one of my favorite podcasts of the Year
okay not because we agreed but it was
interesting to see where he was at and
we had a good discussion right here
though yeah I mean I'm sitting right
yeah yeah this will be the second most
interesting yeah you're so funny thank
you but but we had a good conversation
by the way I'll enjoyed Antonio Brown
and now Tony Brown was full on
disrespectful when he was here he just
kind of disrespected the whole audience
us and it ended up being a very good
podcast but
tell me what plays Trump wouldn't go to
on media where they would trash him
where would he not go to would he not go
to CNN would he not go to MSNBC would he
not go to Jimmy Fallon
he went everywhere right now flip let me
flip this on you how many times have you
seen
Obama Clinton Hillary any of those guys
Biden go on Fox ever how many times the
answer is never except for once do they
do they do let me make my point here the
point I'm trying to make two is the
following as much as we can say you know
whatever we want to say about guys like
a trump or anybody else if you're
willing to go in the den and no they're
going to trash you no they're looking
for their moment agree or disagree man
that's that's the last thing you can say
is that's a thing a thin skin person
won't even go in there so there's a bit
of an argument for that but go ahead
um also Bernie will do the same thing I
think that's why I respect Bernie as
well I think I don't know if that has to
do a trumpet skin or not and I think you
can make an argument for him being thin
skin and that's exactly why he branded
these platforms to air his grievances
um but I think didn't Trump have a
pretty unique relationship with the
media like for instance so you asked me
that question like uh Trump went
everywhere which was true so I'm trying
to think okay well the Democrats then
like they don't Fox News that's true but
do they do they go on media much at all
when they were in office like was Obama
making regular appearances or Fox News
or he was making his rounds and going
talking to people that gave softball
questions
was this during like campaigning or was
this like when he was by the way when he
was in office and by the way I've
watched I've watched every single one of
uh uh Obama's interviews on late night
or he would go on any of this stuff I I
liked watching him but the challenge was
when he went on any shows it was like so
what's your favorite song
and it's like what do you mean what's
your favorite song versus uh Trump would
go on is why are you hiding everything
you know so then and by the way so who
would be thin skin so here's a question
for you the perfect perfect thing to be
thinking about we'll invite guests to
the podcast okay
somebody will email us and say send us a
list of questions did you do that
yeah
[Laughter]
thanks guys
do me a favor do the best in your
ability to look your best he's like I
got sweatpants blue or gray oh we don't
care about that that's all I got but
here's the point the point is the point
is the final one here's a point we'll
invite somebody to the podcast and
they'll say send us a list of questions
okay and send us a list of topics
and they'll say ask me whatever you want
to ask me sure to me the person that
says send me the list of questions has
got thin skin and is worried about
getting caught versus to me the guys
like ask me anything Trump doesn't say
what questions are going to be asked me
he just says goes he knows they're gonna
ask him whatever they're going to be
asking him versus the left hey send me
the questions matter of fact send me the
debate questions to know what kind of
questions can you edit this question
this way for me Hillary so I can be a
little bit more and then writers Brazil
got called out of course supplying them
so that is the ultimate thin skin
Community if we want to kind of go there
and by the way you know you can make
that argument but Trump trumps the one
thing about Trump he likes to go into
that he likes going on I was just going
to say that I think you can be two
things at once I think Trump can be
argumentative not afraid of debate go
into the lion's den and like be ready
for a fight a brawl but he could also be
thin-skinned well meaning like you can
be both good point it in skin does not
mean does not necessarily mean afraid to
fight and I think we have to Define our
terms right so thin skin you get
insulted but that doesn't mean that
you're not going to show up and defend
yourself but there are plenty of people
who won't show up they just won't show
up because they don't have the argument
that is not Trump's problem he will show
up that's right largely because he is
thin scared when you show up and you
just say with a random [ __ ] every time I
don't know if it's as impressive but I
didn't hear not say that again well when
you show up and just say random [ __ ]
every time because it feels like that's
what Trump's Mo kind of was but um uh
got him elected him elected that is true
he got called out on all this all the
random quote random stuff you know what
you know what it is like it's kind of
like this it's kind of like uh uh the
Republican who goes to a hardcore left
school and makes it out okay when you
make it out
you've been destroyed by everybody on
the left in that school that your
arguments have to be better yeah but he
didn't have any arguments for anything
no no I I what I'm saying to you is no
for him to go to the opposing side I
think that's a your developing muscle
when you do that that's what hurt their
feelings because they loved him oh he
destroyed he declared for president I
think the part about Trump that is his
challenge here's the challenge he's got
my opinion I could be wrong but I think
he wants to fight everybody and 99 of
people are now worth fighting and it's
just kind of like what'd you say what'd
you say like like you know you go to the
club with the one friend and he just
what'd you look at me for what what he's
that guy so worse
what he just tried to do today he's
trying to fight him too much 99 of the
fights at the club Listen People gonna
bump into you at the club yes if you if
you would you do it's like dude it's a
tight spot people don't bump into each
other just kind of walk through you
almost have to tell him when we make it
to the bar which is only 20 yards away
about nine people are gonna bump into
you they're not trying to fight you
they're gonna bump into you it's okay I
think that's his deal
power for what you just said I just say
I say this all the time I go at this
point in my life because I went to
Florida State are you talking about
steroids keg parties and fights and hot
chicks that's Florida State for you free
tip out there and I would say this
that's College that's College Florida
State you guys all know there but I
would I say this I go if I'm going to
fight somebody at this point in my life
I'm gonna know them we're gonna have a
past we're gonna have a relationship
they're gonna do something that screwed
me over when I told them not to I'm like
to Pat's point I'm not even fighting the
random dude who bumped into me in the
bathroom line and I think to use that
metaphor that's what Trump is doing it's
okay to fight Nancy Pelosi it's okay to
fight Chuck Schumer sure but to fight
the Santa well no to Santa's that's fine
too very single but to fight every
single comment on Twitter and defend
yourself is just like dude I think the
big issue with that too and I saw
flashes of this during the the 2016
primaries and everybody on the left
probably a lot of people on the right
were waiting for Trump to switch up
because um there were a couple primaries
that he lost where he came on stage and
he was actually really gracious he was
like Ted Cruz ran a great campaign here
you know you guys weren't here and that
was good and I was like oh okay cool so
he does have a bit of like I don't
remember any of those he did it a couple
times because every time it happened I
was like okay if this guy wins
presidency at the very least that's not
possible yeah he's gonna be like
there's a word I'm looking for show me
or something he's going to be a good
sport about it and everything's gonna be
okay but uh man it wasn't and Trump sold
himself as a businessman he acts the
least like a businessman I've ever heard
in my entire [ __ ] life right if
you're a supervisor and your employees
[ __ ] up and your manager comes to you
you never blame your employees it's your
responsibility it's your shift if you're
a manager and the store owner comes to
you you never blame your supervisors
that's your store right if you're a
store manager and the CEO of the company
comes to you or if Congress goes to the
CEO you're like oh am I in play right
it's you you own it that's why you get
such a good points we say it's on me
exactly and Trump was the master of
passing the buck now if he wanted to
blame the Deep State on the Democrat
side even at that I don't think he
should do it because you're the
president and it's your job to work
through it and that's what you sold us
on you talked about corporate inversions
in Ireland and you talked about bringing
people together and things and you said
you were going to do that and you didn't
um but the problem is he attacked all of
his friends too right he attacked
sessions he attacked his attorney
general he attacked his heads every
nominated head he's got people in his
past cabinet he's got like every single
person like if you were on Trump's
friends list you were like two weeks
away from being on his burn list and it
was like Jesus like can you not hold a
single [ __ ] friend in the same place
it's like he loves the drama it's like
the chick who loves drama and you're
like I just I just want to have a nice
dinner or but she's on her phone
what he's saying is essentially speaking
of drama the reason that Biden got
elected I'm not trying to troll you or
trigger you but the reason Biden got
elected at least we so we thought was
like can we just calm the temperatures
of the drama sense nobody was like but
it is the best guy ever he's been in
politics no zero people even the people
that voted for him it was just like a
enough with the Trump and the trolling
and that's what got him alive listen
years ago they would say there would
never be a president from New York you
know New York City because what New York
DNA is like right you know Chris
Christie oh he's too much he's too much
he had one one of those Town Hall
meetings I don't know if you remember
like 15 years ago or 12 years ago in
East Jersey put this lady in her place
and said well video went viral like yeah
but that would never work in Alabama
that would never work when Iowa and
that's just not a model so if you know
George steinburner if you know New York
if you know Gotti if you know the people
that came out of New York the athletes
the politicians the business people
that's New York it's a very normal of a
New York so anybody that lives outside
of New York is not used to that George
steinburner fired the head coach not the
head coaches Skipper what do you want to
call him do you yeah the head coach
general manager not the general manager
yeah the manager yeah he he fired and
rehired the guy three times he did it
once on National Television
he's like you're fired and he's like
what are you talking about you're fired
it's like you can't fire me like this
and I brought him back and brought fired
him again it's a little bit of a New
York DNA that the rest of the world is
just not used to I will say and he tried
to bring that to politics well I mean it
obviously worked in some areas and it
didn't work in some areas so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]